john already brought it up sopra first
chart what's going on here
yeah last week you know we we we're
looking at this bounce when you look at
this little blue circle uh shaded circle
that i that i put in there that's where
we were at last week and so we were
looking for do we start to get
continuation to the upside in the ratio
and we have in fact um as you see in the
on the right hand side of the chart so
this kind of resembles if you look back
to like september of last year
we had this 20 plus uh
uh percent correction and then we came
back down re-tested that one threshold
and then uh started moving up from there
so um
want to see that ideally but you know at
a minimum um you want to see that one
threshold um you know hold obviously and
maybe
stabilize above one
but yeah i mean i ideally we we continue
higher what you don't want to see
obviously is for us to go below and then
re-test it
and it becomes resistance but for now
looking really good
awesome expl exchange supply shock ratio
uh maybe not as bullish as it's been but
still not bearish either is my read
yeah so
we have three different things here um
the one that the one that's slightly
bearish is the highly liquid ratio so
this is looking at the movement of uh
coins from the highly liquid entities uh
to liquid entities so
the the ratio ticking down just means
coins are moving to the highly liquid
amenities
i think you're starting to get some of
this reflecting in price um i'm actually
kind of short-term i wouldn't say like
short-term perish but
i'm a little cautious over the next two
days i think we probably come down and
like recess like 53k
partially because of this
also exchange flows are just flat over
the last two weeks they're down like 490
btc which um of course like isn't
bearish to say it's just not you know
strongly bullish so it's just neutral um
and then like when you look at the
derivatives uh funding
um so you look at the perpetual swap
funding
we we've had a really big spike over the
last like 24 hours and so to me you know
what that shows is like
traders are basically trying to trying
to leverage long the dip
and then oftentimes like when you see
funding go in the opposite direction of
price it usually resolves in the
direction of price so like
one example would be when we came off
that failed breakdown of 30k
um i remember uh we did it we did one of
these and i was saying that we were set
up for
favorable conditions for short squeeze
and the reason was the same kind of
setup but the opposite so you had
funding uh going more negative as price
was going up and open interest relative
to market cap was going up so in other
words you had people piling on shorts as
price was going the opposite direction
and that resolves of course we have this
massive um i remember at the time it was
it was a huge move um
to like
like mid or upper upper 40ks
off off those lows so
i don't think we're gonna have a move of
that magnitude but i'm just saying it's
um you know when you when you start to
see that's just a good example when you
start to see funding go in the opposite
direction of price especially as open
interest is increasing as a proportion
to market cap
you're susceptible to these moves that
oftentimes resolve in the direction of
price so
um i think you have some some late
shorts that hopped in and over the last
24 hours i mean you look at like some of
the aprs on on funding uh like i'll pull
it up right here
you know we're looking at like on some
exchanges up to like 67
apr like on buybit for example uh which
often times by bits wrong uh while at
the same time ftx is much lower at like
20 percent um
and derivatives there was at 38 so like
overall the you know funding funding is
uh
seen a big spike over the last 24 hours
so i don't know i'm kind of short-term
cautious obviously like long-term
picture hasn't changed at all but just
to you know for hodlers like who cares
right but i'm just saying you know just
just be wary if we start to trend down
over the next couple days um come back
down and re-test that 53k area um and
even as low as that that re-testing that
break above the point of breakdown for
may at 50k i don't think that's out of
the cards but um i think like that 53k
is probably a logical area that's also
like the trillion dollar market cap area
too so i just think there's a couple
different things that confluence that
that kind of point to that being a nice
little area to maybe scoop up some btc
over the next couple days
but yeah